>>> UKRAINE IS DENYING RUSSIA'S
UNSUPPORTED ALLEGATION THAT
UKRAINE IS PREPARING TO USE A
SO-CALLED DIRTY BOMB ON ITS OWN
TERRITORY, THAT KIND OF DEVICE
CONTAINS RADIOACTIVE MATERIAL
BUT IS FAR LESS POWERFUL THAN A
NUCLEAR BOMB.
RUSSIA'S DEFENSE MINISTER MADE
THE CLAIM DURING CALLS WITH HIS
WESTERN COUNTERPARTS INCLUDING
U.S. SECRETARY OF DEFENSE LLOYD
AUSTIN.
UKRAINE SAYS THIS IS AN ATTEMPT
BY MOSCOW TO SIMPLY ESCALATE THE
WAR WITH RUSSIAN MISSILES AND
DRONES TARGETING THE COUNTRY'S
ELECTRICITY AND HEATING
NETWORKS, THE UKRAINIAN
PRESIDENT IS WARNING ONCE AGAIN
OF A DARK COLD WINTER AHEAD.
MORE THAN A MILLION AND A HALF
ENERGY CUSTOMERS DIDN'T HAVE
POWER OVER THE WEEKEND.
CNN'S CLARISSA WARD WAS AT THE
SITE OF ANOTHER STRIKE EARLY
TODAY IN MYKOLALV.
>> Reporter: TWO S-300 MISSILES,
ONE LANDING RIGHT BEHIND ME, YOU
CAN SEE THE SIZE OF THAT CRATER
AND THEN THE SECOND LITERALLY
SLAMMING RIGHT INTO THAT
APARTMENT BUILDING.
NO ONE HERE CAN SEEM TO WORK OUT
WHAT THE TARGET WAS.
THIS IS A RESIDENTIAL AREA,
THERE'S APARTMENT BUILDINGS ALL
AROUND.
I WANT TO SHOW YOU OVER THERE
THIS IS A CHILDREN'S PLAYGROUND.
OKAY?
YOU CAN SEE WHAT'S LEFT OF T
NOW, THE STRIKE HAPPENED IN THE
EARLY HOURS OF THE MORNING AS I
MENTIONED, SO NO CHILDREN WERE
OUT PLAYING, BUT I THINK IT
GIVES YOU A FEEL FOR JUST HOW
CHALLENGING IT IS.
>> AND CERTAINLY RAISES A LOT OF
QUESTIONS BECAUSE WE'VE SEEN
PLAYGROUNDS TARGETED IN THE
PAST.
GENERAL ME NOW RETYRRELL GENERAL
MARK HERTLING.
GOOD TO SEE YOU AS ALWAYS.
LET'S PICK UP SO WE SAW, RIGHT,
THERE'S CLARISSA IN MYKOLALV.
I DON'T KNOW IF IT'S TECHNICALLY
A BACK AND FORTH.
WE'RE HEARING FROM RUSSIA
UKRAINE IS GOING TO USE A DIRTY
BOMB, UKRAINE PUSHES BACK.
YOU HAVE THE COMMANDER OF GROUND
FORCES IN UKRAINE SAYING THE
ISSUE IS THAT WE ARE AND SHOULD
BE WORRIED ABOUT PUTIN USING
NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
OFFICIALS ON BOTH SIDES ARE
GOING TO PUT THINGS OUT BECAUSE
THEY WANT TO CRAFT A NARRATIVE.
WHAT TO YOU WHEN YOU HEAR ALL OF
THOSE STATEMENTS, WHAT DO YOU IS
THE REAL STORY THERE?
>> WELL, WHEN YOU COMBINE THIS,
ER
ERICA, TO WHAT IS HAPPENING ON
THE BATTLEFIELD, YOU KIND OF PUT
TOGETHER THE NARRATIVE THAT
RUSSIA IS SCRAMBLING RIGHT NOW.
THEY HAVE OPENED UP
COMMUNICATIONS AGAIN, THEY HAVE
NOT DONE THAT WITH SECRETARY
AUSTIN, HE IS THE ONLY ONE THAT
RUSSIA HAS BEEN TALKING TO OVER
THE LAST SEVERAL MONTHS, THE
LAST TIME THAT GENERAL MILLEY
TALKED TO THE LEADER OF THE
RUSSIAN MILITARY WAS MONTHS AGO.
SO THEY'RE TRYING TO ESTABLISH
AS YOU JUST SAID THAT NARRATIVE,
BUT THEN YOU COMBINE THAT WITH
WHAT IS HAPPENING ON THE
BATTLEFIELD AND, YOU KNOW,
TRUTHFULLY THERE'S ONLY ONE
DOCTRINE TERM TO USE FOR THIS
AND IT'S SCRAMBLING.
THE RUSSIANS ARE BEING BEATEN IN
MULTIPLE AREAS AND THEY ARE
TRYING TO PATCHWORK THEIR
RESPONSES TOGETHER TO CONTINUE
TO TRY TO DRIVE A NARRATIVE THAT
THEY ARE SUCCEEDING.
THEY ARE NOT.
THEY ARE BEING BEATEN ON THE
BATTLEFIELD IN BAKHMUT, WHICH IS
SOMETHING THEY POURED THE
WAGONER GROUP INTO, THEY'RE
SEEING DEFEATS IN KHERSON, LAST
NIGHT THE UKRAINIAN MILITARY
ACTUALLY LIBERATED DOZENS MORE
TOWNS IN THAT OBLAST.
SO YOU'RE SEEING THE POTENTIAL
FOR ADDITIONAL BATTLEFIELD
FAILURES WHILE RUSSIA CONTINUES
TO JUST STRIKE CIVILIAN TARGETS,
JUST LIKE CLARISSA JUST SHOWED.
IT'S JUST -- IT'S TROUBLING,
IT'S WAR CRIMES AND IT JUST
GIVES ME THE INDICATION THAT THE
POLITICAL MASTERS IN MOSCOW ARE
JUST SCRAMBLING TO TRY TO CRAFT
SOME TYPE OF NARRATIVE THAT THEY
CONTINUE TO WIN, WHICH THEY'RE
NOT DOING.
>> WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT THE
SCRAMBLING I WAS STRUCK BY SOME
ACCOUNTS THAT WERE GIVEN TO CNN
BY PEOPLE IN KHERSON WHO
UNDERSTANDABLY DIDN'T WANT THEIR
NAMES USED, THEY WERE WORRIED
ABOUT RETRIBUTION BUT TALKING
ABOUT THE MOVEMENT THEY'RE
SEEING ON THE GROUND, RUSSIAN
ADMINISTRATIVE OFFICIALS ARE
MOVING OUT, THAT NEW TROOPS WHO
SEEM TO IN THE WORDS OF ONE
PERSON NOT REALLY KNOW WHERE
THEY ARE OR WHAT THEY'RE DOING
SEEM TO BE MOVING IN.
THE MOVES THAT WE'RE SEEING IN
THAT AREA, YES, COULD BE FURTHER
EVIDENCE OF SCRAMBLING AND
ISSUES, BUT ON A BROADER LEVEL
THIS IS ALSO A REALLY IMPORTANT
AREA RIGHT NOW.
>> IT IS CRITICALLY IMPORTANT.
WHAT YOU'RE SEEING ON THE
RUSSIAN SIDE IS WHAT'S CALLED A
TACTICAL WITHDRAWAL.
THAT'S THE OFFICIAL NAME FOR IT.
AGAIN, A VERY TOUGH MILITARY
OPERATION TO EXECUTE BECAUSE
YOU'RE LEAVING SOME PEOPLE IN
CONTACT WHILE YOU'RE TRYING TO
WITHDRAW YOUR TROOPS IN OTHER
PLACES.
RUSSIANS HAVE BEEN IN TROUBLE IN
KHERSON FOR ABOUT FIVE WEEKS
NOW.
THEY HAVE FORCES ON THE WESTERN
SIDE OF THE DNIPRO RIVER WHICH
ARE ABOUT TO BE SURROUNDED AND
CAPTURED BY UKRAINIAN FORCES.
THEY HAVE BEEN ATTEMPTING TO
ENCIRCLE THOSE FORCES FOR
SEVERAL WEEKS NOW.
AND THEY KNOW THAT THEY'VE GOT
TO PULL THE ADMINISTRATIVE
GOVERNMENT THAT THEY THEN PLACED
AND WHEN I SAY "THEY" I'M
TALKING ABOUT THE RUSSIANS, THAT
THEY HAVE PLACED OUT OF THAT
AREA DURING A WITHDRAWAL AND
IT'S GOING TO BE CHAOTIC.
SO, YES, THEY HAVE PUT MORE
FORCES IN THERE, BUT THE FORCES
THAT THEY ARE PUTTING IN THERE,
ERICA, ARE THE SAME ONES WE HAVE
BEEN TALKING ABOUT FOR MONTHS
THAT HAVE BEEN MOBILIZED THAT,
NUMBER ONE, AREN'T VERY GOOD
AND, NUMBER TWO, THEY'RE JOINING
UNITS THAT HAVE BEEN MAULED OVER
THE LAST SEVERAL MONTHS SO M
MORALE IS VERY LOW.
IT'S A DISASTROUS OPERATION
THAT'S BEING CONDUCTED IN THE
SOUTH WHILE AT THE SAME TIME THE
WAGONER GROUP IS STARTING TO
LOSE IN THE NORTHEAST.
>> REALLY QUICKLY BEFORE I LET
YOU GO, AT THE BEGINNING OF THE
WAR WHEN THERE WAS TARGETING
SPECIFICALLY OF INFRASTRUCTURE
AND SENDING PEOPLE OUT OF
UKRAINE, THERE WAS TALK THAT
PART OF THIS PLAN, RIGHT, WITH
AS TO FLED EUROPE AND THE WEST
WITH REFUGEES, TO BREAK DOWN
SOME OF THE SUPPORT FOR UKRAINE.
COULD SOME OF THAT
INFRASTRUCTURE TARGETING BE AN
EFFORT BY PUTIN TO DO THE SAME
THING NOW HEADING INTO WINTER?
>> OH, IT'S CERTAINLY DOING
THAT.
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT HE IS DOING.
HE IS CREATING -- OR ATTEMPT TO
GO CREATE A HUMANITARIAN
DISASTER WITHOUT HEAT, WITHOUT
WATER, WITHOUT ELECTRICITY.
ALL THOSE THINGS THAT A CIVILIAN
POPULATION DEPENDS ON.
BUT WHAT WE ARE FINDING
INTERESTING IN KHERSON IS AS
RUSSIA IS TELLING THE CITIZENS
OF KHERSON TO GO EAST AND GET
OUT OF THE AREA BECAUSE THEY ARE
AFRAID THAT THEY MIGHT BE
INJURED, AT LEAST THAT'S WHAT
THEY'RE SAYING, MANY OF THE
RESIDENTS ARE STAYING THERE.
IT'S ALMOST LIKE THE DECISION DO
YOU STAY OR LEAVE DURING A
HURRICANE.
YOU KNOW, ARE YOU GOING TO BE
THERE WHEN THE BATTLEFIELD
HAPPENS TO BE INCREASINGLY
INTENSE OVER YOUR HOUSE?
THAT'S WHAT'S HAPPENING AND WHAT
WE'RE SEEING IS MANY UKRAINIAN
CITIZENS ARE COUNTERING THAT
THREAT BY STAYING IN THEIR HOMES
IN THE KHERSON REGION, WHICH IS
JUST PHENOMENAL.
BUT THE WINTER IS GETTING
TOUGHER, IT'S STARTING TO GET
MUCH COLDER NOW AND WITHOUT
ELECTRICITY AND HEAT IT'S GOING
TO BE DIFFICULT.
>> IT CERTAINLY WILL.
LIEUTENANT GENERAL MARK
HERTLING, ALWAYS APPRECIATE YOUR
INSIGHT.
THANK YOU.
FREDERIK PLEITGEN IS LIVE IN
ZAPORIZHZHIA, UKRAINE WITH THE
LATEST.
FRED, WHAT CAN YOU TELL US?
>> Reporter: THE BIG QUESTION
RIGHT NOW HERE IN THE SOUTH OF
UKRAINE AND WHETHER OR NOT THE
RUSSIANS ARE REALLY REMOVING
THOSE FORCES FROM THAT AREA
AROUND THE TOWN OF KHERSON.
THERE ARE INDICATIONS THERE
MIGHT BE A WITHDRAW, THAT MAY
HAVE ALREADY STARTED BUT IT
COULD HAPPEN IN THE NEXT COUPLE
OF DAYS.
THE HEAD OF UKRAINE'S MILITARY
INTELLIGENCE BELIEVES THE
RUSSIANS ARE BUILDING UP FORCES,
TELLING CIVILIANS TO LEAVE THE
AREA.
BEFORE WE WENT TO AIR WE GOT NEW
INFORMATION FROM THE RUSSIAN
INSTALLED PUPPET AUTHORITIES IN
THE AREA, CALLING ON THE MEN
STILL IN THE TOWN OF KHERSON TO
JOIN A TERRITORIAL DEFENSE UNIT.
COULD BE AN INDICATION THAT THE
RUSSIANS WANT TO MAKE A STAND.
THE UKRAINIANS SAY ON THE
GROUND, THEY CONTINUE TO MAKE
GAINS IN IN THE SOUTH.
>> MAKING THIS CLAIM WITHOUT ANY
EVIDENCE THAT UKRAINE HAS SOME
KIND OF PLANS TO USE A SO-CALLED
DIRTY BOMB.
THAT WOULD BE SOME KIND OF BOMB
WITH RADIO ACTIVE RESIDUE
ATTACHED TO IT.
THE U.S. DISMISSES THIS, WHAT'S
THE INTERNATIONAL REACTION TO
THIS?
>> Reporter: FIRST OF ALL, THE
U.S. DISMISSES IT, YOU'RE RIGHT.
BUT ALSO THE INTERNATIONAL
COMMUNITY MOST DISMISIT AS WELL.
IT WAS INTERESTING BECAUSE THE
DEFENSE MINISTER OF RUSSIA, HE
SAID ALL THIS IN A CALL WITH
LLOYD AUSTIN, BUT ALSO WITH THE
DEFENSE MINISTERS OF FRANCE,
GREAT BRITAIN, AND TURKEY AS
WELL.
MAKING THESE CLAIMS.
FRANCE, THE U.S. AND BRITAIN
CAME TOGETHER HAD A COMMON
STATEMENT SAYING THIS IS FALSE
INFORMATION.
SAYING THEY HOPE THE RUSSIANS
DON'T USE THIS FOR ESCALATION ON
THE BATTLEFIELD OF THEIR OWN.
THE UKRAINIANS ARE SAYING THE
SAME THING, THEY'RE A MEMBER OF
A NONPROLIFERATION TREATY AND
THEY DON'T HAVE ANY NUCLEAR
WEAPONS OR NUCLEAR WEAPONS
PROGRAM.
THEY BELIEVE THIS IS THE
RUSSIANS MAKING A MOVE.
IT'S UNCLEAR WHAT'S BEHIND THIS,
BUT TROUBLING RHETORIC COMING
FROM THE RUSSIAN DEFENSE
MINISTER P.
>> FREDERIK PLEITGEN FROM
ZAPORIZHZHIA, STAY SAFE.
THANK YOU.